I don't remember having my own Barbies
but my cousin had a box of them they
were like all yes
you know the we would cut the hair and
do all that stuff but I got the fold out
house one Christmas when I was young and
that was every I was a Barbie dreams yes
the dream house that folded out like
honestly coming into this movie it was
like that was that was such a priority
was those the sets and then getting them
getting to see them be built right in
front of us and they were just huge
real-life versions of the dream house it
looks incredible so amazing and so
beautiful and it's like the first thing
I said to gretels you know when we first
sat down talked about the movie I was
like I'll follow your vision whatever
you want this Barbie movie to be like
let's do that except I just have one
favor please please please can we have a
dream house where she has a slide that
goes from her bedroom down to her
because that is my goal in life she was
like yeah sure that's your thing that's
your thing and I was like yes that's not
like your character
oh my God I'd love that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]